in his first congressional testimony
since becoming u.s secretary of state
anthony blanken made it clear to
legislators his upcoming meeting with
top chinese officials in alaska won't be
a social call
we intend to raise and we we will raise
uh the host of issues some of which have
already been touched on today
uh that concern us um we'll also explore
uh whether there are avenues for uh
cooperation
and we'll talk about uh the competition
that we have in china with china to make
sure that
uh the united states has a level playing
field
and that our companies and workers uh
benefit from that
blinken and white house national
security adviser jake sullivan
are meeting senior chinese foreign
policy officials yongshi
and wang yay at a time when the biden
administration has declared beijing
the us's main global rival state
department officials say
the problems washington has with beijing
are many hong kong
xinjiang tibet pressure on taiwan
broader human rights abuses the south
china sea the mekong
economic pressure arbitrary detentions
the origins of
covet 19 other issues the china u.s
ministerial meeting will come at the end
of the first in-person overseas trip
for blinken and defense secretary lloyd
austin
while observing pandemic-related
protocols austin and blinken will hold
strategic talks with their japanese and
south korean counterparts
on tuesday and wednesday austin will
also travel to new delhi for meetings
with
indian military leaders
china's military ambitions including its
efforts to control
international waterways and to develop
nuclear weapons
will be discussed the u.s will also be
raising north korea's nuclear program
and the crisis in myanmar former u.s
assistant secretary of state danny
russell says
in-person meetings with washington's
allies will repair the damage done
during the trump administration
but he expects blankens meeting with
chinese officials
will be the start of a long process of
engagement
i think that it's clear that joe biden
isn't going to rush into china's arms
and he's not going to rush to try to
solve every problem
as i said he understands that he needs
to
deal with the chinese from a position of
greater relative strength
if he's going to
be able to move
chinese decision-making and policies
in directions that they may not
necessarily want to go
u.s officials say the meeting in
anchorage in alaska
is about engaging with a key global
challenger
initiatives and strategies can come
later
that is if the u.s thinks it can trust
the people
across the table rosalyn jordan al
jazeera the state department